what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and right now A lot of
people are really really looking forward
to Deadpool 3. you have questions yes I
I had a lot of questions I'm sure you
had a lot of questions but rest assured
we're going to answer them right now
especially right now since Ryan Reynolds
has been doing interviews for his movie
spirited with Will Ferrell which by the
way my hair is pretty good but today we
have some really cool news about
Deadpool 3 and some info about what the
plot could possibly be about and if this
is true or even some of it is true it
sounds pretty dang good and I think a
lot of fans are really really going to
like this now I first want to start off
by talking about the possibility of
Channing Tatum's Gambit appearing in
Deadpool 3. now first things first this
is a Multiverse movie we know that we
know Ryan Reynolds is Deadpool and Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine are going to start
off in the fox universe but end up in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe we know
there's going to be Multiverse jumping
here here so literally anything is
possible Deadpool is a character who
breaks the fourth wall he has imitated
Batman before there is a possibility he
could even jump to a DC Universe it
sounds crazy I know but with Deadpool
literally anything is possible and
according to Daniel rpk Ryan Reynolds
has had talks with Channing Tatum about
being in Deadpool 3. so everybody
automatically thinks yes Gambit however
the report does state that Ryan Reynolds
talked to Channing Tatum about being in
Deadpool 3 in some role even if not as
Gambit now there could be many reasons
of why Channing Tatum would show up in
Deadpool 3 not as Gambit but I do think
there's a pretty good possibility he
could show up as Gambit this is a role
that Channing Tatum really really wanted
to play this was confirmed it was done
but when the fox Disney deal happened it
kind of fell through and based off of
what Channing Tatum told us before and
has expressed publicly before he was
really really disappointed and sad about
it so I'm sure one hand he would love to
play Gambit he would love to be in
Deadpool 3 and maybe be in a universe
where that movie actually happened and
he was actually Gambit and they could
even make fun of it in fact I'm sure
they would but at the same time perhaps
maybe it's a little bit of a sore spot
for him a sore subject and maybe he
doesn't want to dive into that role
unless it's going to be him really being
Gambit but I can already see a scene
where Deadpool and Wolverine go to a
universe they see Channing Tatum and
he's a different character and they call
him Gambit and he's like what and
they're like oh sorry I guess that
didn't happen in this universe as well I
can see so clearly a small Cameo from
Channing Tatum and Ryan Reynolds just
making fun of him after all we got our
small Cameo from Brad Pitt in Deadpool
2. it was super quick but hey it was
worth it and it was hilarious so one
might expect the same thing however I
personally hope that he would get to
play Gambit at least one time in his
career my fingers are still crossed that
Kevin feige will call him and possibly
ask him to play Gambit in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe one day but we'll
wait see now to get into a rumor going
around about what the plot could be for
Deadpool 3. this one's really
interesting because it involves
Wolverine's son Dawkin now I know some
of you may be thinking docking could be
the villain of Deadpool 3 but actually
today we have heard about some casting
calls for a female villain but we'll get
into that in just a bit but first let's
dive into this rumored plot report now
again without seeing any kind of plot
leak or any type of Insider report we
know that this movie is going to be a
Multiverse traveling movie we know it's
essentially going to be a Multiverse
road trip with Deadpool and Wolverine
eventually leading the two of them into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
according to some other reports some
other X-Men are going to be brought into
the MCU as well and this new report
States how now this rumor starts off by
saying that Wolverine had a son during
the events of the Wolverine but he
doesn't know about it that kind of
sounds like what we just experienced
with She-Hulk spoilers if you haven't
seen the finale but Hulk has a kid now
if your comic and you already know this
but they have officially introduced scar
into the MCU maybe he'll go on to fight
Wolverine's son Doc in one day but
Wolverine had a son during the Wolverine
according to this report and according
to the rumor Dawkin will end up getting
sucked into the MCU and could possibly
be the main mcu's Wolverine now this
right here if it were true would Merit
an entire video of its own of course
right now we don't know if this is true
or not it's just a rumor but I gotta say
it does kind of make sense if they don't
want to replace Wolverine in the MCU
right away fans have been talking about
that for a while it's going to be hard
to replace Hugh Jackman as Wolverine he
was the Wolverine he was almost perfect
A Little Too Tall but pretty perfect so
how do you go about getting a Wolverine
in the MCU but replacing the Wolverine
while bringing his son into it isn't a
bad idea and since Dawkin is pretty
similar to Wolverine in terms of
abilities and Powers it kind of could
work until eventually Marvel Studios
decides to bring in an actual Wolverine
because what's kind of cool is this can
all reset after Secret Wars Dokken could
come in and be a wolverine until the
events of Secret Wars happen and then
after Secret Wars I'm assuming a lot of
Heroes are going to go back to their
normal regular universes and the same
could happen for dakan and then after
that we could get a new Wolverine I'm
okay with this and this sounds like a
really good idea I would however love to
see Hugh Jackman's Wolverine in secret
Wars which I think should happen and
would be a shame if it didn't let's just
hope that this isn't a one and done by
Hugh Jackman and he's willing to stick
around but we still have more to talk
about in this rumored plot which we'll
get into in just a bit but first big
thank you to Mint mobile for sponsoring
this video
most people know about mint mobile
because of Ryan Reynolds but most people
don't know about mint Mobile's amazing
quality now I live in the mountains and
service isn't too good however mint
mobile sent me a free plan and I get
better service with their plan than I do
with my other provider but what's crazy
is their plan is so much cheaper mint
mobile offers Wireless for just 15 bucks
a month they give you the best rate
whether you're buying for one or a
family and at mint mobile families start
at only two lines all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high-speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5G Network plus mint Mobile's Modern
Family Plan lets you mix and match data
plans so everyone gets the amount of
data that's right for them and you can
use your own phone and keep your same
number and contacts so to get your new
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
including the Modern Family Plan go to
mintmobile.com Cosmic that's
mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your wireless
bill down to 15 bucks a month and mint
mobile mobile.com Cosmic so the rumor
says that Deadpool meets Hugh Jackman
for drinks then the two of them get
involved in a multiversal road trip to
the MCU to find Dakin before he becomes
evil now if you're not familiar with
Dokken in his story he has a pretty
tragic and sad origin story dakan or
akihiro was the son of Wolverine and His
Japanese wife itsu however sadly when
itsu was pregnant with Dawkin she was
murdered guess by who the Winter Soldier
he murdered her to try to get Wolverine
to go back to madrapore now Romulus took
the baby cutting him out of his mother's
wombs and it's believed that Dawkins
survived because of his healing Factor
he inherited from his father Romulus
left Dokken at the doorsteps of a
Japanese couple who could not have kids
so they took this as an answer to their
prayers however eventually they would go
on to have a child and Dawkin growing up
believed that his family didn't really
love him would go on to kill the child
would eventually go on to kill his
adopted mother as well and his adopted
father not being able to kill Duncan
killed himself so as you can see pretty
tragic plus not to mention Wolverine
wasn't there at all so Dawkin believed
his father abandoned him so you could
probably see how Dakin has some pretty
bad anger issues and while the story
might not be exactly the same in
Deadpool 3 you can see how this person
might become bad so essentially the
rumored plot says that Deadpool and
Wolverine are trying to find Dokken
before he becomes Super Evil I like this
idea however there is a downside to this
this kind of is somewhat of the same
plot of Deadpool 2. trying to stop the
kid Rusty or firefest from going on to
becoming a huge villain that would kind
of be the same plot which is why I think
this might not happen but again it still
is a cool idea that if they did it a
little bit differently would actually
work but like I mentioned this says that
Dawkin wouldn't actually be the main
villain it would just kind of be a part
of the story which I think would be
pretty cool because again it's a good
idea to have docking in the MCU however
like I said I'm recent casting call for
Deadpool 3 describes a female villain
the casting call is calling for a female
lead in her 30s to 50s and this
character will be a foe to Deadpool and
Wolverine and this was shared by Daniel
rpk now right now it's speculated that
this villain could be danger danger is
the physical manifestation of the
software program used to power the
danger room the training room for the
X-Men and when Ryan Reynolds actually
did his first video for his teaser
talking about coming up with a script
and a plot idea for Deadpool 3 when he
was sitting on the toilet reading a
comic it was a comic with her on it so
this is why it is believed that the
villain is going to be danger which I
think would be pretty cool to see and I
think Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman
would handle that very well and like I
mentioned this movie is rumored to
supposed to bring other X-Men into the
MCU as well and with danger being the
villain this could work out with her
being the villain it's all set up there
for it to happen how it would happen not
sure but let me know what you think
about all of this in the comments down
below do you think this would be a cool
villain and a cool story for Deadpool 3
and do you think Channing Tatum should
play Gambit in Deadpool 3 as well leave
all your thoughts down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to the channel so you don't miss out on
any of the latest news for live updates
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf